so look yes originally there was
supposed to be a subscribe joke here
but this image of kilauea covered in
youtube subscribe buttons took me so
long to make that i'm just gonna
take a step back this time around and
let the image speak for itself
hello and welcome to the new review your
source for everything anime and manga
and today it's back to hunter hunter and
time to discuss the past the present
and future of a certain best boy being
killer zoldick and i wanted to get into
this because a while ago i made a very
similar video featuring gone
exploring what happened to him after the
chimera antarct as well as his potential
future in the series and i even
questioned whether or not i think he
should indeed step back into the story
or if his character arc was
satisfactorily concluded there will be a
link to said video in the description
below if you would like to watch it and
i recommend you do because
i don't know just do it but all of these
questions and more can also be applied
to killer and not only that but at face
value these questions are even a bit
harder to answer with killer as he can
be seen as being left in something of a
limbo state and the arguments for both
his continued involvement
as well as his continued absence are
pretty compelling but to really dive
into the heart of this issue we need to
understand
where killua was approaching his series
journey from killua's purpose in hunter
hunter is probably the most vague of our
main protagonist you know you can look
at gone and that's easy he is on a
mission to find his father a nice
tangible goal and he has a clear yes or
no answer when we think of whether or
not he achieved it
and in this case it would be a yes gone
found jing and that is the primary
argument as to why his character is
complete
similarly you can look at karapaka who
has another tangible goal which is to
recover the eyes of the kurt clan
members
another super clear ambition does kraft
pika have all of the eyes yet yes or no
and no he doesn't so his story will
continue hopefully then we can look at
leorio whose goal was to make a ton of
money and become a doctor so that he can
treat people in need has laira become a
doctor yet
no he hasn't so just as with krapika his
story continues albeit very much in the
background but
what is killer's goal or purpose in
hunter hunter his journey is much more
complex than the more palpable goals of
the other protagonist and that's because
he acts as something of an antithesis to
the others because his lack of purpose
is paradoxically enough his
purpose the other three all have an
innate sense of what their lives are
meant to be dedicated to
and so they strive towards that
meanwhile kilauea has been told all his
life what he is supposed to be
which is an assassin and his involvement
in the beginning of the series can
basically be summed up as
no i'm gonna go and play with my friends
instead f you
dad and what occurs from here is
killer's search for a goal and or
purpose which results in his priorities
changing as the series goes on but for
most of it you can probably identify his
purpose as wanting to protect and spend
time with his first and best friend mr
gone and yes it's definitely much more
complicated than that because kilowatt
comes with a lot of baggage in regards
to the zordik family
and him emancipating himself from his
relatives is another undeniable driving
force particularly in the case of illumi
however with all of that in mind the
first and most obvious question we need
to ask ourselves is did killua
eventually find his purpose and i would
very much argue that he did although it
was not in gone but rather alka by the
end of kilauea's involvement in hunt
hunter thus far he has achieved a sense
of peace within himself
and he has a solid grasp on what he
wants to do with his life for the first
time
which is to travel the world with alaka
and keep her safe from the grasp of
their family so it's a bit tricky
because killer's greatest driving force
within the bulk of the series
was certainly resolved which is his
relationship with gone
and rather tragically resolved as well i
would equate gone and kill
his relationship to that of an
emotionally abusive partner you know
kilauea starts out the series and
becomes a bit smitten with the old gone
forming one of the most legendary
partnerships in all of anime manga but
as time goes on
and on it just becomes clear that gone
doesn't feel
quite the same way i've said it before
i'll say it now and i will say it again
but gone is an incredibly selfish
protagonist who has
no idea just how lucky he is to have a
friend like kilauea who will dedicate
himself
entirely to ensuring that gon is safe at
all times but how does gone respond to
that
well by putting himself in more and more
danger culminating in him being more
than willing to throw his own life away
for a completely meaningless mission in
the slaughter of nephipito from killer's
perspective it's like watching your
partner walk down a path of
self-destruction
and as much as you try to intervene
that's just what's going to inevitably
happen
and in that scenario you just need to
separate yourself from that person which
killer does and in doing so he probably
achieves one of the happiest endings
that any character in the series is
going to be capable of getting not only
does he leave gone to pursue a greater
purpose but there's also the added
benefit of gone no longer being on that
path to destruction
he loses his ability to invoke none at
least for the time being and now he's
safe and sound on whale island where
kilauea doesn't need to worry about him
and that
is significantly better than most of
these types of relationships will end
in real life so good on you go on and
kill a while but in that way you could
say that killer
story and hunter hunter came to a
satisfactory conclusion given that it
was pretty directly tied to gohan's
character up killer found a new goal and
then he walked off into the sunset never
to be seen again
except for when he was briefly seen
again recommending biski to karapika but
more importantly killawatt was finally
able to achieve a solid sense of purpose
in regards to alaka and while no that
isn't a
tangible goal that one can really
achieve i do find it to be
an unfortunately satisfying conclusion
unfortunate because in my opinion more
kilowatt is never a bad thing in this
world but i will most certainly take an
ending like this because it could have
ended up significantly worse for him and
stepping into the more meta aspect of
hunter hunt for a second we are also
faced with the reality that we're on a
very bad path ourselves at the moment
where hunter hunter may never end and if
it does it's probably going to be within
the next arc or two
togashi's age and frequency of output
does not
necessarily allow for us to put kilowatt
back into the spotlight because we have
enough loose ends to tie up without
adding him back into the mix
so the way i tend to see things as that
gun and killua are both done
it's not that we'll never see them again
but they won't be major protagonists and
what's after this story is going to be
dedicated
to finishing off the characters of
karapika layorio and even hisoka
probably jing as well of course that is
just my opinion and there are many ways
that you could disagree with that
some of which we are about to explore
because if we do ignore hunter hunter's
publication
issues then there are indeed a variety
of ways in which kilowatt could see a
return as a protagonist because not 100
of things regarding him have been solved
i suppose the most obvious of which is
his relationship with illumi when we
last left these two illumi was scheming
to figure out a method by which to
control killua so that he could buy
proxy control alaka and thus have access
to the greatest power ever showcased in
this world
so one way that i could see a
satisfactory return of kilowatt is to
settle this conflict with illumi whether
it be through combat or another means
and i guess it would be nice to have
this come full circle because illumi is
kilawa's ultimate antagonist really and
he has been the specter lurking over him
for the large majority of hunter hunter
so why not have him directly confront
and overcome his brother the question i
will ask is is it necessary though
i would argue no but a lot of that
mindset comes from knowing what hunter
hunter is as a series
if this was any other shonen series i
would say 100
that kilauea needs to confront illumi
directly to have a satisfying ending but
this is hunter hunter and we cannot
treat it like a typical shonen because
plot points and foreshadowing are all
frequently abandoned
in favor of achieving a sense of realism
within the world
and what i mean by that is that you know
sometimes in real life you just don't
have your epic climactic conclusion
because that's life and hunter hunt has
made a point of invoking this realistic
approach on a number of occasions i mean
actually come to think of it one has
anything in hunt hunter ever ended in
that typical satisfactory manner that we
would see in many other shonens the
closest i can come is greed island where
against all odds gone did win the game
through a fun last minute bit of trivia
but in every other arc things tend to
end very suddenly
and not in the way that they were set up
to and this is also the main argument
that i would use against those who
insist that gon has to return because he
has unfinished business with hisoka
which is true but in this world that's
just not a good enough reason in my mind
and neither is killer's unfinished
business with illumi and to add to that
it's also entirely possible that illimi
will meet his own end during the current
arc because he is aboard the blackwell
one
and destined for a deadly date with
hisoka so if filmy is taken out during
this arc then well that's all the more
reason
the killer not to be brought back into
the fold there are still other arguments
so one of which is the gyro train of
thought and i have to say this every
time but look if you're an anime only
watcher this will probably confuse you a
bit because it was not
included in the 2011 adaptation but gyro
is a chimera ant who was stated by the
narrator of hunt hunter
to have some sort of destined meeting
with gon in the future and obviously
that has not happened at this point not
even in the manga but this serves as the
main driving force behind the insistence
that gone story isn't done
and there is a profound difference
between dismissing this and dismissing
something like i just stated before with
the whole hisoka rivalry which is that
togashi made a narrative point to state
that gon
and gyro will meet this isn't an
implication of an event or the desire of
a character expressed in speech
it was an inevitability stated by the
narrator of the story which is why i do
take it a lot more seriously but what
does that have to do with old killer
well it's because if there was any way
to bring him back into the action
a call from his old flame gone would
certainly do just that
if gon was ever in any trouble i have no
doubt that kilwa would race a godspeed
to his rescue and should we ever get to
a stage where it is time for this gyro
and gone business to actually play out i
guarantee you that gone is probably
going to be in a hell of a lot of
trouble but then again thoughts along
the sign generally assume that we will
ever get to much less conclude the dark
continent so this
is very much a dream at this stage but
kilauea could see a resurgence in other
ways
because even removing illumi from the
equation he is still zoltic and i highly
doubt that silver is just going to allow
killer to do whatever he wants for the
rest of his life i know this is going
back an awfully long way but one thought
that does bring to mind is when silva
had that particularly sinister moment
and claimed that killua would return
home as they air one day and regardless
of how that occurs be it peaceful or
explosive or just downright murderous
that is another thread to maybe
potentially solve i mean who else is the
air going to be there's every chance
that illumi is going to be dead by the
end of the current arc milikey is well
he is in no way fit be the head of such
an organization
galato is uh oh yeah carlito could
probably do it after his experiences
with the phantom troop and of course
alaka is directly tied to killua so
kilauea is very much the natural heir in
this situation
but whether or not togashi feels the
need to tell that eventual story
is completely up for grabs another one
of those things that would be nice but
not absolutely necessary but in essence
a lot of this is just very wishful
thinking and as stated i myself have
long since come to the conclusion that
killua's part in this story has long
since ended and as much as i love him
there is nothing wrong with that at all
of all of our protagonists in the series
kilauea has undergone the most
heartbreaking journey
full of physical mental and emotional
growth becoming completely
unrecognizable from the incarnation of
him that we first met during the hunter
exam
i really don't think that one could ask
too much more from a character who
already exudes one of the most
phenomenal presences in the entire manga
medium this boy has done his time
provided us with an exceptional journey
and laying it all to rest here is in no
way
a bad thing but what do you guys think
please do let me know down in the
comments below or even join my discord
server
and if you'd like to see more videos
like this then please do go and check
out some of my other content or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
hunter hunter glory delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time